non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait de sport nous sommes ce jeudi 31
mai dans cette superbe enceinte du
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à l'extérieur
de cette enceinte le coup d'envoi du 11e
trophée à des entreprises devrait être
donné dans 45 minutes aux alentours de
17h30
le concept de ce rendez-vous plus de 600
coureurs venus de 60 entreprises vont
s'affronter dans diverses épreuves dans
ce vélodrome donc et l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines et bien sûr à
la fin il y aura un gagnant pour
m'accompagner dans cette émission quatre
chroniqueurs d'exception ont fait le
déplacement alors nous allons passer
tout de suite au programme de l'émission
du coup aujourd'hui dans un premier
temps vous aurez le droit à un très gros
coup de projecteur sur le trophée les
entreprises et nous aurons à quelques
plusieurs interventions de notre
journaliste nicolas landry qu'on
retrouvera dans quelques instants
qui nous fera vivre l'effervescence
autour de cet événement dans la seconde
partie de l'émission
nous ferons un tour d'horizon de
l'actualité sportive dans le département
nous parlerons notamment de la très
belle victoire en 8e de finale honneur
de versailles on en parlera dans
quelques instants pierre chevalier mais
avant de développer ces thèmes
on ouvre notre page focus
[Musique]
dans notre focus nous allons nous
intéresser au parcours de ce 11e trophée
des entreprises les concurrents qui sont
répartis en groupes de trois dans trois
catégories hommes femmes et mixtes
auront fort à faire ce jeudi soir le
programme du parcours course à pied sur
1 5 km une course d'orientation de 2 5
km du golf une épreuve de radeaux sur
500 m un relais vtt de 1 65 km par
équipier du run and bike sur 1,3 km un
sprint final de 400 m ça la question sur
ce thème
messieurs un parcours technique ou pour
le loisir technique c'est rouge loisirs
sévère des revers verts gagnent jarrier
pourquoi parce qu'on est sur des
distances très très courte donc qui sont
accessibles au plus grand nombre
donc très bien pour la découverte
découverte du sport mais mais bon pour
le pur du vélo ou du vtt sur des
parcours plat en dessous d'eux
20 30 km on n'est pas du tout soit
l'endurance on est sur du c'ur du sprint
de pure et sur les épreuves très rapide
donc on est là sur même pour des
personnes qui ne sont pas aguerris
c'est accessible à tout le monde genlis
vous aussi vous avez voté vers pas mieux
mieux non mais je vois qu'il ya de tout
dire on veut pas appeler ça vraiment une
épreuve futures épreuves sportives mais
pas les compétitions je vais pas redire
ce qu'il a dit il a tout à fait raison
je pense que c'est pas non plus basée
sur la compétitivité mais plus sûr se
regroupent et déjà dans un esprit
sportif et qui se voit après au sein des
différentes entreprises qui participent
à cet événement moi je juste intervenir
c'est que c'est pas parce que on est sur
du loisir qui a pas de compétition je
pense que parmi les équipes qui sont
constitués y en a qui sont là pour
gagner et en a qui se sont entraînés il
ya plusieurs mois voilà et c'est pas
parce que les épreuves sont courtes
qu'on ne s'entraîne pas pour aller
chercher c'est la meilleure performance
sur du très court il y a dix à la
technicité sur les sur certaines
épreuves donc il faut être le plus
efficace possible et c'est pas parce que
on est sur du court le triathlon il ya
plusieurs distances dans les catégories
officielles celle et chez les seniors
et on commence du très court avec alors
j'ai pas des distances en tête mais sur
le vélo les gars font une dizaine de
kilomètres et alors et on va jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'ironman de 180 kilomètres donc
tout est balayé sur le sur le choc
trianon donc là on parle t'on peut
parler quand de compétition même si on
reste sur un esprit loisir puisque
celle-ci bateau à laurianne jarrier on
vient de retrouver nicolas d'andry
nicolas landry c'est à vous est ce que
le stress monte à quelques minutes du
départ vous trouvez peut-être on va
peut-être retrouver c'est pas sûr
on cherche encore est ce que vous êtes
là nicolas nourrice
ah on n'entend pas un nicolas d'andré
malheureusement on va retrouver en
j'espère en tout cas pierre chevalier
vous avez quelques je pense que c'est
une très belle addition de multisports
c'est à dire que c'est comme disait yann
c'est c'est plutôt sur une approche
choisir mais qui doit rester et qui est
accessible pour qu'un maximum de
d'hommes et de femmes en entreprise
puisse pratiquer dans le plus pur esprit
d'équipé et de manière à deux manières
on va dire raisonner en termes d'efforts
on a des sports qui sont très divers pas
aussi complémentaires que les trois du
triathlon que diana citées mais je pense
que c'est une série c1 une bonne
occasion en loisir en loisir plus pour
ceux qui sont spécialisés dans che dans
chacun des sports de pouvoir un peu
s'exprimer et que les équipes
d'entreprises puissent bien participer
et puis faire justement faire porter
haut les couleurs de leur entreprise de
manière accessible en pierre chevalier
on va avoir un tout de suite avec
nicolas d'ombré qu'on a enfin retrouvé
alors voilà nicolas est ce que le stress
monte
des gardes
ok tant pis pour un nicolas d'andria
j'espère qu'on retrouvera quand même
dans cette émission
georges gomis nous a pas entendus sur la
question mais un organisateur
on c'est vrai que c'est comme laisser
des personnes qui ont de différents
niveaux donc on doit adapter la pratique
et donc par rapport à ça je pense que le
l'organisation a bien réfléchi
le vélo c'est un des sports favoris des
français donc à peu près 22 24 % de
français pratiquent au moins une fois
enfin qui pratiquent une activité
physique font du vélo et notre activité
physique physique qui est la plus
pratiquée c'est la course course à pied
donc je trouve tout ça dans le trophée
des entreprises ont tout ça ça a été
réfléchi je pense que les organisateurs
ils ont ils ont fait des distances
courtes ce qui permet de pouvoir de
pouvoir comme ans de pratique est assez
facilement et de ne pas être dans le
rouge physiquement et de prendre du
plaisir et l'autre façon de penser deux
des organisateurs
je pense qu'aussi le niveau technique
des choses parce que tous ces décès des
actifs dans fins et des pratiques qui ne
ment pas une grande technique sauf sauf
le golf et le golf et le comment et le
canoë et le canoë je pense aussi dans ce
sens là ils vont prendre le courant dans
le dans le sens pas dans le sens inverse
ce qui va faciliter et puis bon c'est
des gens intelligents et ça permet de
sortir de là avec du plaisir justement
genre est ce que vous avez un
commentaire sur cette épreuve de canoë
400 mètres sur l'eau
ouais il vaut mieux que ce soit sur
l'eau ce que si on s'est beaucoup plus
compliqué mais bon georges lundi ces cas
là le sage du courant certaines équipes
aussi sur les pratiques à noël c'est
très compliqué ça très très beau piqué
des dessins du plusieurs pour le maire
de pau je pense retrouver la voir en
tout cas de nicolas donc assez old town
on a retrouvé nicolas nicolas
c'est le direct comme on dit à chaque
fois les attend beaucoup
on la retrouve et on entend sa voix en
tout a été dit qu est ce que tu jour
leur chevalier est ce que cette épreuve
du canoë c'est peut-être l'épreuve où
tout va se jouer
c'est peut-être la plus originale parce
que c'est effectivement le sel qui va
falloir le plus coordonnés en équipe
et là autant il peut y avoir beaucoup de
participants quand l'expérience en
course à pied
en natation en sprint éventuellement
golf mais en calories qu'un appui
sûrement beaucoup moins donc ça va être
moins facile de performer rené bike et
du run and bike
le run and bike est une discipline qui
demande énormément d'organisation et de
coordination entre les entre les
participants parce que leur run and bike
sur 1,3 km
finalement c'est peu mais ça peut le
placer différence énormément de
différences parce que vous pouvez aller
vous pouvez faire beaucoup de temps ou
en gagner énormément
si vous êtes très bien synchronisés très
bien de très bien organisé on remarque
en tout cas dans ce trophée des
entreprises qu'il faut un esprit
l'équipe à un georges gomis ans ben oui
ben il faut un esprit qu'il peut
vous l'avez souligné tout à l'heure
incertain ils ont il ya des gens qui ont
dû peaufiner leur leur comme en leur
temps des mouleurs leur trio pardon et
par rapport à ça ils ont dû s'entraîner
prendre un peu de temps trouver les
affinités
bon après c'est bon je pense que c'est
le but recherché d'une compétition comme
ça c'est aussi de dessous d un petit peu
les équipes au niveau de l'entreprise
et si on peut le faire consolider les
liens par rapport aux sports est de
pouvoir participer à une activité
ensemble prendre du plaisir ou gagner
ensemble ou pas se passer un bon moment
ensemble
bah je pense que c'est c'est le but de
2,7 de cet événement alors on vous l'a
annoncé vous l'avez entendu nicolas
landry est avec nous enfin alors nicolas
landry est ce que tout se passe bien sur
le départ
je suis avec des habitués de la
compétition nathalie et thierry de la
team orange
[Musique]
c'est toujours très sympathique de golf
alors est ce que vous sentez comment
vous la sentez cette époque de golf
c'est la grosse inconnue puisque
présentation pénalité on a six équipes
team orange on est là pour se faire
plaisir et pour faire de notre mieux
voilà vous avez vu donc des participants
déjà chaud déjà qui veulent se faire
plaisir et puis les supporters je peux
vous dire qu'ils sont rendez-vous nous
verrons sur le parti qu à leur merci
beaucoup
nicolas landry genlis un commentaire sur
ce créateur %
j'ai des réalités ex est un état
d'esprit expansion une ambiance
électrique un vrai ouais ça ça a l'air
il ya l'air d'avoir du monde à
l'extérieur
et puis bien motivés et bien prêt à
passer de bons moments
alors nous allons maintenant passer à
notre page débats le deuxième thème de
notre émission c'est parti
[Musique]
le sport au travail peut-il devenir
obligatoire en suède certaines
entreprises ont franchi le pas depuis à
quelques mois ils proposent à leurs
salariés
d après midi entière de sport pour que
du coup leur emploi ils se sentent mieux
dans l'entreprise et soient plus
performants cette mesure aura également
permis de diminuer l'absentéisme de 1
22% selon une étude de l'université de
stockholm doit-on imposer le sport au
travail en france nous avons posé la
question aux saint quentinois
oui je pense que l'entreprise devrait
s'investir dans le sport l'arbousier
si on impose ça va au niveau de la
réglementation en na'vi falloir payer
les gens à faire du sport je pense que
tout ce qui est imposé mais pas bon mais
après
au travail ça fait une récréation
finalement pourquoi pas si on peut
ajouter au travail quelque chose de fun
pourquoi pas l'imposer non je pense pas
sap est une obligation c'est une bonne
idée une bonne initiative ça peut avoir
des ministres ça
par la suite ça dépend quel genre de
travail oui je pense que ça peut être
une bonne idée
de faire selon par contre on peut
choisir les modalités mais ça peut être
intéressant de d'obliger ou d'invité
sérieusement les collaborateurs à bouger
on sait qu'on est beaucoup plus efficace
quand on bouge c'est quelque chose qui
permet de déstresser déjà amélioré les
conditions de vie je pense que ce qui
permet d'avoir une meilleure hygiène de
vie entre guillemets parce que justement
enfin après chaque séance on se sent
bien du coup ça peut motiver pour le
travail la question sur ce thème
messieurs doit-on a posé le sport au
travail vous votez oui non on fait un
petit duel entre eux en ayant déjà rien
gens vont commencer
alors pour vous non alors j'ai dit non
tout simplement parce que ce mot imposer
voilà ce que vous imposez qui le gêne
com propose je préférerais propose qu'on
propose du sport dans les entreprises je
suis à fond tout à fait d'accord parce
qu'il est largement prouvé que le sport
est déjà assez beau pour le pour la
santé pour le côté physique mais c'est
aussi bon pour l'état d'esprit la
cohésion de groupe et dans une
entreprise c'est essentiel ce sont des
valeurs essentielles pour travailler au
sein d'une entreprise en toute bonne
harmonie quoi donc je vais proposer des
scènes de sport serait très très très
bien l'imposer on nous impose tellement
de choses actuellement dans notre
société que l'on obtiendra peut-être pas
l'imposer le plus qu'on voit là
uniquement pour ça bien de jarrier moi
je vais dire oui on peut imposer le
sport mais dans le sport qu'est ce qu'on
me faut pas oublier que les échecs c'est
du sport le poker c'est du sport donc du
coup des gens qui n'ont pas besoin d'une
active en mobilité pour les parties
d'échecs en fin de journée dans
l'entreprise je milite dans je milite
pour
je milite pour le sénat qui est votre
sport et l'activité sportive de toute
façon maintenant voilà ça peut être
aussi une manière de faire d'autres
activités dans le sein dans le cadre de
l'entreprise
voilà mais je rejoins jean sur le mot
imposé c'est vrai que c'est quand même
dommage d'obliger les gens à faire
quelque chose les salaires de marché en
suède ça a l'air de marcher en suède
contre oui peut-être que ça fonctionne
en jade apprécié par année ils ont pas
la même
la même éducation la même heure nous
n'est pas nous sommes un pays latin 70%
des habitants pratiquent le sport au
moins une fois par semaine et 50 % le
pratiquer trois fois par semaine et donc
efficace sur les chiffres pour la france
en france on est à 40 % une fois par
semaine voilà donc une moi je pense que
ça permet après c'est pas pour autant
que la suède a mis meilleurs résultats
maintenant dans l'espoir de les sports
de neige
oui ils sont ils sont au dessus parce
que là les structures leur leur
permettent et puis le climat le leur
permet mais mais bon voilà c'est une
culture et c'est vrai que le français
n'a pas la culture du sport et surtout
n'a pas la culture de la compétition je
pense que beaucoup beaucoup de français
pratiquent une activité physique mais ne
pratique pas la compétition et voilà
c'est peut-être là la nuance est la
différence qu'il peut y avoir entre
certains pays --la france
moi je regrette que la compétition n'est
pas une plus grosse importance dans le
dans la
dans la vie des dans la vie du quotidien
dans le quotidien des français
alors on voit en ce moment même les
images du trophée les entreprises qui va
s'élancer dans quelques minutes indienne
déjà rien eh bien on va finir ils vont
pas finir arras et il n'y a qu'en france
que valve il n'y a qu'en france qu'on a
qu'on a priori à un problème de culture
de culture sportive l'impression que dès
l'école et donc après par extension en
entreprise le sport est comme la
cinquième roue du carrosse et que de
toute façon une carrière dans le sport
c'est ça passe
après une carrière une carrière des culs
d une carrière de médecin de deux chefs
d'entreprises etc
et pourtant le
il est plus à prouver que le sport
apporte un certain nombre de vertus de
qualité et notamment dans l'esprit
d'équipé qu'on peut voir qu'on peut
retrouver en entreprise donc l'imposé
effectivement c'est c'est peut-être un
peu fort
d'un autre côté il faut aussi contourner
la contourner les réticences initiales
dans la culture française par rapport au
sport mais c'est peut-être avec la
manière forte donc éventuellement
peut-être proposer proposer de manière
intime lampe le mans imposer ce qui
dérange
oui parce que on est on est dans une
pratique une pratique loisir ou une
partie sportive ou une pratique de
compétition et ça doit ça doit faire
partie d'un choix perso d'un choix
d'entreprise projet d'entreprise aussi
pour certains mais tous sont au tout ce
qu'ils ont fait le con fait le choix de
participer à certaines compétitions où
certains une certaines manifestations
comme celle-ci en entreprises en ont
retiré des bénéfices au quotidien dans
la vie de l'entreprise et c'est une
évidence
georges 2011 a pas entendus sur la
question écoutez le sport le sport en
france une politique sportive dans
l'obésité pour non moi je le fait
d'imposer parce que quand on impose pour
moi c'est pas c'est pas la meilleure des
choses donc pour avoir des résultats il
faut une politique et sportive et en
france elle n'est pas malmener puisqu'il
ya pas mal de choses qui seront faits
pour pour comment pour la pratique on ne
peut pratiquer en loisir on peut
pratiquer en commet en libre on peut
pratiquer en fédération peut pratiquer
on peut pratiquer à différentes pas
différent échelle maintenant je trouve
que on progresse on prend de la france
progresse aussi à ce niveau là on n'est
pas au niveau de certains pays ou
l'allemagne où quand ils se lancent dans
des politiques sportives
il arriva il arrive à y injecter tout
beaucoup d'argent et puis derrière il ya
des résultats mais maintenant la france
progresse et
on se trouve je trouve qu'on répond si
on répertorie tous les tous les gens qui
font du sport non identifiée c'est à
dire que les skateurs les skateurs les
les comment les les
les skateurs les gens qui font qu'ils
font du football en loisir ladoire le
dimanche ou qui jouent au rugby au qui
joue au rugby les gens qui font de la
pétanque
aussi je pense qu'on est on sait ça on
ne compte pas dans le dans le décompte
dans le décompte final mais il ya
beaucoup de pratiques non non identifiés
de pratiquants pardon non identifiées
donc je pense que la france progresse eu
énormément les mentalités changent les
mentalités changent et la france l année
quand même 10 % de personnes qui font du
sport moins une fois par semaine sur les
cinq dernières années
voilà donc sa méthode simple pour de
plus en plus de ça m'étonne pas parce
que notamment l'entreprise et les
commandes et les mental qui ait changé
et dans le monde de l'entreprise si le
monde dans l'entreprise si mais c'est
encore une meilleure chose à perdre
deux-trois un exemple sur les boîtes
américaines qui sont implantés en france
elles ont apporté avec elle la culture
sportive d'entreprise et tout ce qui on
en connaît je pense plein qui bossent
pour des boîtes américaines en france et
ils ont cette culture là entre midi et
deux soit d'aller à la salle de sport
parce que les bulles les buildings sont
équipées de salle de sport soit d'aller
courir entre collègues soit d'aller
faire un petit tour de vélo ça prend une
heure le temps de rentrer après deux
premiers de salade et on est je pense
encore plus efficace à son poste de
travail en début d'après midi
quel sport il faut mettre en avant dans
les entreprises
jean imposé mettre en avant leur mise
la pratique la plus en plus on va dire
la plus facile
c'est la course à pied ensuite on fait
beaucoup de yoga et de course at il joué
ou après il ya aussi les salles de sport
pour les grandes entreprises qui font
construire un centre de sport on s'est
même des bâtiments et voilà et c'est
vrai que sous forme de yoga aussi ou 2
ou de danse aussi il ya des cours de
danse qui se font je pense à la zumba
des choses comme ça qui sont un petit
peu en vogue depuis un certain temps et
toutes ces activités que ce soit à
l'intérieur à travers soi des cours aux
diverses ou des salles de sport mais à
l'extérieur à travers une course à pied
qui est tout à fait à la portée de tout
le monde d'accord merci jean pour avoir
clôturé cette thématique on ouvre
maintenant du coup une nouvelle
thématique avec ce après ce débat
enflammé ce 11e trophée des entreprises
se déroulera à 99% en extérieur avec des
épreuves en pleine nature
donc comme on le disait précédemment il
y aura de la course à pied du vélo dans
un cadre quasi idyllique pardon pour les
amoureux de la nature
est ce que ce type de manifestation peut
sensibiliser les participants aux sports
en extérieur oui ou non vous êtes
partagés georges un petit duel
jean-georges ses partisans deuxième duel
de la journée bonjour bonjour je suis
chaud très grande forme c'était quoi la
question est ce que ce type de
manifestation peut sensibiliser les
participants aux sports en extérieur en
extérieur oui je dirai oui c'est ce que
j'ai dit ouais c'est pas que ça tombe
bien
oui parce que forcément toute
organisation comme celle là
mais ça fait parler de sport en règle
générale et ça peut donner envie à tous
les gens qui vont passer autour doyen
vie de participer à ce genre de 2,2
d'activités sportives ou de compétition
et forcément ça ne peut que développer
et avoir un retour positif sur le fond
d'ailleurs on voit le départ de la
course donc quatre tomes voit un départ
comme ça le départ d'un dernier à
l'issue d'un dernier
ah oui partiront seront dans les mêmes
conditions ils ont fait ils ont fait le
de tout faire cela mais c'est vrai que
je vois là je dis que tu vois tout ça
mais ça donne
obligatoirement c'est comme ça c'est
comme l'histoire la télévision comme
roland garros qui vient de démarrer
par exemple on voit jamais au tas de
gens avec des raquettes tennis à la mène
dans les villes que cai à roland garros
donc c'est forcément qu'il ya un effet
sur la population le fait de voir du
sport dans quelques tout quelque forme
que ce soit georges c'est à vous est-ce
qui vous a convaincu à moitié à moitié
donc c'est déjà pas mal c'est japon non
mais par rapport à ce qui dit bon bah
c'est moi je pense que déjà il ya pas
mal de gens qui pratiquent déjà le la
course à pied ou d'autres activités du
physique
donc même si on en entreprise on absurde
des fois on est enfin si ça peut être
des licenciés ça peut être des pratiques
en eau libre c'est sur une manifestation
comme ça je pense pas que ça puisse
faire prendre conscience aux gens de 2,2
de prendre une licence dans une
fédération ou 2 ou 2
tout commence
ou de prendre une licence dans une
fédération ou de faire un peu plus de
sport je pense que ce que ça peut
apporter
c'est le fait de se retrouver dans
l'entreprise et de pouvoir justement par
le biais le biais de cette équipe-là de
de cette manifestation de pouvoir se
dire ben écoute écoute et ben c'est
l'année prochaine on va mieux se
préparer on va essayer de dd de
commandes de d'apporter sa pierre à
l'édifice de progresser de faire
progresser l'équipe
il a dans ce sens là oui j'ose je le
pense aussi bienvenue jarrier ce qu'il y
ait ce que georges vous a convaincu oui
oui
non mais moi j'étais gt gt aussi courte
enfin je disais oh sinon que c'est pas
ce type de 2 c'est pas le fait que ce
soit à l'extérieur que ce qui va aider
les gens à aller vers l'extérieur ce qui
va aider les gens à faire du sport en
extérieur
bah c'est la météo tout simplement je
pense que en région parisienne c'est
compliqué je dirais que beaucoup de gens
se remettent aux sports à partir du
moment
enfin ou à une activité physique parce
que je pense que quand on fait du sport
quelle que soit la météo
on ira faire du sport voilà maintenant
quand on pratique une activité physique
justement parlez de pluie il commence à
pleuvoir de l'épreuve ballot mais vous
vous posez la question au mois de
novembre les réponses sont totalement
différentes
donc c'est c'est une bonne publicité
pour le sport en général ça peut donner
s'il ne pleut pas trop ça peut donner
des idées des envies comme le jean le
préciser notamment avec un pic de
pratiquants de tennis de roland garros
comme il va y avoir un pic de pratiques
de foot dans les rues pendant la coupe
du monde mais c'est évidemment à ces
puissantes de poser ce type de question
au mois de juin que qu'au mois de
novembre
on va essayer de retrouver nicolas
d'ombré dans quelques instants pour
qu'il le commente un jour le départ
ce départ de l'épreuve des gens est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec pierre
ça dépend finalement de la période de
l'année là on est dans une période
plutôt estival
ça donne envie de sortir même s'ils
commencent à pleuvoir l'extérieur oui
mais ça c'est sûr pour quelqu'un qui
comme moi qu'il ya qui a pratiqué le
rugby
faire du sport l'extérieur quand il fait
très très mauvais a special one serait
plus agréable
donc forcément le temps fait il fait
beaucoup
c'est c'est logique que c'est tellement
logique quand il fait beau et orbi à
plus de volontaires pour les matches du
pour les matches du mois de mai que pour
les matchs du moose février non quand
même produit dans le réduit à des
joueurs de rugby poule finale
y'a pas de monsieur voilà le cycliste
n'est pas un joueur par contre on ne
joue pas au vélo et c'est pour ça que
vous avez choisi le cyclisme sur route
j'ai pas ce souci de météo puisque je
roule en structure couverte
oui mais le sport à l'extérieur je pense
que c'est une bonne chose
2 il ya de plus en plus de salles de
fitness
de sanofi ce net de fitness mais le
sport à l'extérieur demande d'autres
comme en vertu c'est à dire un mental
déjà parce qu'il ya la vie il faut
vaincre la météo il faut il faut
s'obliger à sortir et donc je pense que
de ce côté là aussi il ya comment il ya
à redire il ya à redire
est-ce qu'on fait du sport parce que
c'est sais comment c'est en salle il
pleut pas mais à l'extérieur on est
mieux mais je voudrais juste dire un
petit mot aux gens qui ont la qui disent
ah non aujourd'hui je vais pas je vais
pas aller enfin non c'est trop dur
d'aller faire du sport vraiment on a un
bien-être
une fois qu'on a fait une séance
sportive et je le disais tout à l'heure
dans mes chiffres 20 2 % d'absentéisme
en moins et bien en suède et 20 chez go
sport
mais bien sûr à partir pas moi juste là
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui doivent
sécher le boulot pour pouvoir aller
faire du sport quand ils en ont besoin
donc je crois l'avoir fait alors il y
aura du golf sur le parcours du trophée
des entreprises dans quelques instants
et il y aura également dans les
prochains mois avec la ryder cup et en
septembre prochain avec l'open de france
fin juin à saint quentin nuit des
événements qui pourrait booster
l'engouement pour ce sport dans les
yvelines c'est le thème de notre coup de
projecteur à l'aube d'un événement
historique en france avec la première
ryder cup qui sont organisées sur le
territoire français au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la fédération
française de golf veut surfer sur ce
rendez-vous pour développer la pratique
du golf en france
donc au niveau de la fédération
française ont misé un maximum sur les
infrastructures et notamment sur les
golfs des alentours pour happer
également sur les golfeurs
professionnels sur l'échiquier
international en termes de résultats
lors des tournois
ce n'est pas forcément brillant que du
côté les français pour rappel nous avons
seulement un joueur dans le top 100
mondial avec alexander levy qui est 46e
alors que l'espagne à 4 joueurs dans le
top 100 dont deux dans le top 15
la question sur ce thème la france
peut-elle devenir une nation de golf
comme l'espère la fédération française
oui ou non on fait un petit duel entre
pierre chevallier et georges gomis
georges 2007 à vous mais si l'on se base
sur ça dépend sur quel principe on se
base sur le bar sur le nombre de
licenciés moi je dirais non
maintenant faites m faire un champion ou
deux de champion oui parce que si on
injecte beaucoup d'argent et on fait une
politique sportive dans ce sens là on
peut avoir des résultats on peut sortir
un voire deux champions ou trois jours
ces man une politique sportive pour tout
le monde ça serait plus pour le haut
niveau
moi je comprends bien l'élite voie lente
pour l'élite oui mais je pense pas qu'on
puisse du jour au lendemain sur
plusieurs années être une nation
vraiment être une nation de golf je ne
pense pas maintenant sortir faire une
politique sportive sortir quelques
champions bon l'espagne à noah 2 sur une
dizaine d'années voire quinzaine
d'années en sortir deux trois ou quatre
dans le top dans le top dans le top spin
oui mais parce qu'ils aident politique
sportive qui a été mise dans ce sens là
pour avoir des résultats à haut niveau
il faut injecter de l'argent et à partir
du moment qu'on attend d'un jacques
beaucoup d'argent et qu'on comprend des
gens compétents c'est pas en restant en
restant dans c dans ses souliers et en
regardant son nombril
il faut aussi
et voir ce que font les autres faire
venir les autres chez soi pas garder
seulement comment aller apprendre des
autres et si on amène de la commande de
la technicité de la connaissance
sportive la diversité dans la dent les
après dans les apprentissages
oui on peut sortir des champions peu
importe l'essentiel c'est de mettre de
l'argent et des gens compétents au
comment aux manettes pour pour une
politique sportive sur plusieurs années
voilà pierre chevalier on part d'être
c'est loin sur le sur le golf et sur le
développement du golf en france
néanmoins en nous avons parmi les plus
belles structures on va dire en europe
pas forcément dans le monde mais cette
son club de golf en france 2 donc du
practice jusqu'au 45 euros et et resort
avec hôtel et et multi activités qui
sont autant de structures capables
d'accueillir à un plus grand nombre que
410 mille licenciés actuellement la
ryder cup va nous permettre de mettre un
gros gros coup de projecteur justement
sur la destination france notamment
juste à côté au golf national de
saint-quentin mais aussi tous les clubs
tous les clubs paris et parisiens
ile-de-france francilien mais aussi par
tout partout en france notamment en
normandie où les américains les japonais
les européens qui vont venir assiste à
la ryder cup vont profiter de ceux de
cet événement planétaire pour aller
découvrir les alentours
ça n'ira peut-être pas jusqu'à jusqu'à
l'ensemble des golfs français mais en
tout cas on a on a des structures pour
les accueillir et notamment grâce à la
projet sans petites structures de la
fédération française de golf qui va
laisser un héritage à la ryder cup c'est
à dire sans structures qui sont ouvertes
proches des centres villes qui vont
permettre d'attirer des nouveaux
pratiquants et de et de mettre un public
plus large
voilà et de développer de développer la
structure parce que quand je dis qu on
part de loin on part aussi d'un avec un
état d'esprit qui n'était pas très
ouverts au départ le golf était un été
et un certain nombre de stéréotypes qui
qui caractérisait ce sport désormais le
goal s'ouvre un petit peu fait sa mule
fait sa révolution
s'adresse aux femmes on est on est on
est sur des statistiques de 70% de
pratiquement 30% moffatt quand femmes
c'est en train de bouger un petit peu
les jeunes aussi sont ciblés donc
maintenant ce qu'il nous faut c'est
mettre tout ça en orchestre après la
ryder cup et notamment il est vrai ça
georges a raison il nous faut rapporte
papou il nous faut des champions
régulier qui soit capable de faire un
peu plus que les coups qu'on a fait sur
les 20 dernières années
un van de velde à l'open britannique a
relevé un levé sur les tournois écossais
gray gadret aussi sur les tournois et
causé au loin l'open de france avec un
remesy qui gagne deux fois levé qui
gagne également sur le territoire
national donc il nous faut des champions
qu'ils soient réguliers à lévis qui on
l'espère soir dans l'équipe on va on va
pousser derrière qu'il ya dans l'équipe
de ryder justement pierre chevallier
on va écouter le président de la
fédération française de golf sur
alexander levy qui est la tête d'affiché
du golfe france en semant on écoute le
principe de toutes nos installations et
lully les golfeurs de la permettre de
d'avoir des installations de meilleure
qualité sur lesquels elle peut
s'entraîner mais également à des non
golfeurs de venir passer un beau lot qui
leur donnera la sensation forcément
agréable de toucher les bases de
distance et sans doute de leur s qui ne
sont certes pas eu
parce qu'on considère aussi veulent fait
c'est une autre des idées reçues comme
un sport difficile
on veut leur on lui dit d'abord et
donner envie aux gens d'avoir alors ce
n'était pas jean luc chavent le
président de la fédération française de
golf qu'on a vu justement l'instant
c'était le président de blue green qui
est qui a parlé il parle de développer
justement le golfe pour tous avec
notamment des activités ludiques des
mini golf des parcours pour pour la
famille c'est le président de la
fédération française et c'est le credo
là c'est le credo de bluegreen donc avec
manuel biotope qui présentait les
différents projets de cette chaîne qui
s'adresse évidemment à tous les non
golfeurs en fait c'est leur objectif
c'est de contourner les freins à la
pratique qui sont le fait que le golf
prennent du temps
donc là c'était plus petites structures
qui se joue rapidement ensuite c'est le
côté ludique c'est à dire le faire faire
honte faciliter la proche du gol qui est
effectivement technique au départ
techniquement difficile mais désormais
on l'a proche de manière un peu plus
ludique et agréable
donc là il ya plein de petites
structures qui vont du minigolf jusqu'au
petit champ droit qui centre
d'entraînement et puis avec des
pratiques qui sont connectés avec des
écrans et qui permettent de jouer comme
on jouerait au bulli finalement donc le
dépasse peut-être aussi son image un peu
vieillotte exact de golf fait sa
révolution doit faire sa révolution
et quoi de quoi de plus quoi de meilleur
quelle meilleure année pour le faire que
qu'une année de ryder cup houle toute la
planète va regarder le golf national
entre le 20 septembre entre le 28 et le
30 septembre
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça vous donne
envie vous de faire du golf quand vous
voyez ce type de structure je me fais
mais qu'elle nous en fait un meilleur
perdu alors très très belle analyse
devant l'ami pierre sueur gauche mais la
partie donc c'est facile mais moi je
reste encore un peu sceptique
c'est vrai que le golf doit s'ouvrir
mais ça reste quand même une discipline
qui n'est pas la portée de tout le monde
et surtout de tous les porte-monnaie
ça reste une discipline quand même
relativement cher et c'est logique par
rapport à au budget au budget mirobolant
est-ce que ça doit représenter pour
l'entretien d'un golf et forcément ils
sont bien obligés de répercuter ces
dépenses sur les les différents
licenciés les différents pratiquants
mais c'est vrai que pour s'ouvrir au
public et à tout le monde c'est très
très viennent tout ce qui est mis en
place
maintenant je pense qu'il faut aussi
jouer sur le côté un petit peu plus
abordable côté financier pour pouvoir le
développer pour développer pour rebondir
sur ce que tu dis est tu as tout à fait
raison sur la sur la sur la pratique la
pratique du golf et sur le fait qu'on
puisse devenir une nation de golfeurs
dira pas forcément dodge mais deux
golfeurs c'est que on a la chance
extrême d'avoir dans les sept sont
structure dolphy qu de quoi contenter
tout le monde
il y a effectivement les clubs privés
associatifs qui sont sur le l'ancien
modèle que tu cites et qui sont
effectivement des structures qui coûte
cher à entretenir c'est dans les coupes
pierre chevalier noir le départ dans
quelques instants
dans moins d'une minute du trophée des
entreprises dans moins d'une minute
voilà les compétiteurs vont s'élancer la
première vague va s'élancer dans
quelques instants
il ya déjà rallié que vous aimeriez y
être dès que je vois une ligne de départ
et une fa surtout une ligne d'arrivée
bien sûr que je suis premier
à vouloir vouloir me battre contre
contre les autres adversaires mais mais
aujourd'hui j'ai pas vu les diffuser
distance qui sont proposés je pourrais
je pourrais aligner sang censés gagner
je ne sais pas non parce qu'il doit y
avoir des vrais coureurs et d y yvon
galoper non tout simplement pour pour
participer l'année prochaine ça sera
avec dormi c'est pierre chevalier
peut-être aujourd'hui avec sa condition
qu'ils aient pas de canoë parce que
sinon on n'arrivera pas au bout tatata
tu sais pas 8 alors il ya quand même 600
concurrents qui vont s'élancer un
georges commises dans quelques instants
est-ce que vous avez un petit message
alors passé souhaite du plaisir et et de
pouvoir comment terminer arriver à leurs
objectifs c'est à dire finir finir et en
bonne santé et en forme pour reprendre
le travail le temps qu'il va y avoir un
peu de pluie un sur le parcours est ce
que ça peut jouer pierre chevallier un
petit peu de pluie pour assister des
hallebardes qui tombe avec avec un petit
peu d'orage oui ça peut jouer mais bon
là ça va les rafraîchir ça va être ce
qui fait il fait quand même assez lourds
avant qu'ils commencent à bourriner donc
s'appeler rafraîchir au rang de terrain
glissant j'en sais pas trop dangereux du
coup cette pluie et c6 et puis d'orages
comme ces derniers jours avec des baux
est clair ça ne va pas me faire courir
plus vite
yann wii party à ces parties voilà
justement ils viennent de partir à
l'instant on voit que les vagues
commencent à partir il on a tous très
motivés vous voyez dans quel état
d'esprit à gan comme ça dans l esprit de
l'objectif que l'on s'est fixé
c'est-à-dire que si on est là pour
s'amuser bien il faut y aller avec le
sourire et avec la fleur au fusil est
sûre il a pourtant gagné bien il faut
s'être bien échauffée pour ne pas rater
et rester concentré tout le long du
parcours
bon en tout cas va suivre avec attention
le parcours sera filmé en sait quelque
chose pour finir l'hiver
il ya dans les structures golf qu'en
france pour tous les publics et pour
tous les budgets
désormais il va juste nous ouvre le
golfe et 410 mille licenciés est ce que
ça inclut et tous les pratiquants qu'on
peut voir sur les terrains de golf
dimanche tu as tu vois que tu as
toujours
recul entre les pratiquants réguliers
mais qui n'ont pas de qui n'ont pas de
licence tu parlais tout à l'heure de la
compétition
c'est ce qu'ils font pas forcément
compétition mais ça aussi entre 600
milles pratiquants dont les quatre cent
mille licenciés et jusqu'à dans les
rêves les plus fous jusqu'à un million
cinq de pratiques or mes soeurs c'est un
voeu qu il s'est même problème pour le
vélo on a des pratiques on a des
licenciés mais le nombre de partis quand
est nettement supérieure et escaut vélo
les facteurs son compte et non pas parce
que maintenant ils ont des incidences
électrique dont les coupables ont parlé
tout à l'heure de tête d'affiche on va
revenir sur alexander levy alexander les
villes la tête d'affiché vraiment du
golf français gilles bouchard on espère
en tout cas qui va réaliser un super
open de france
on les écoute il nous a montré en
gagnant de l'autre en faire un noeud de
la balade manière qu'il avait su gérer
son score son parcours montée en
puissance qu'elle dure et au dernier
tour qu'il rêvait profite de ta
pollution et gérer l'ensemble fedele
score jusqu'au bout donc avec les vies
et non seulement candidat l'élection de
rang mais l'équipe européenne le rappel
de la france est une manière de le
démontrer georges denise c'est ce qu'il
faut une tête d'affiché comme alexander
levy pourra propulser le golf français
dans une nouvelle dimension
les zinédine zidane pour le football
michel platini également nikola
karabatic pour le handball
ado il doit ya voir alexander levy pour
le coach m'a écouté 6 6 et 6 c est un
garçon qui est charismatique qui oui oui
il faut de charismatique il faut être
comme en madih médiatique il faut être
plus favorable à des résultats
et peu importe la personne si on apporte
au drapeau basse ici c'est alexandre
tant mieux pour le golf français pour
tous tant mieux pour la france
et bien ça y est j'ai en écoutant
genre je pensais exactement la même
chose et j'ai fait le parallèle dans ma
tête avec un garçon qui s'appelle qui
est champion de biathlon et ses parts
info carrefour cadet s'est pas pour
autant comme on en parlait mais cas des
très très bons résultats
c'est pas pour autant qu'il ya plus de
licencié est beaucoup plus de
pratiquants est ce important que ce
sport devient très populaire un peu
beaucoup plus bien sûr ça fait très
longtemps que je suis biathlon déjà à
l'époque de raphaël poirée et même avant
ça le jive dit je crois qui était un des
premiers biathlètes où je confonds de
tête avec le
avec le temps je n'étais pas là mais met
donc c'est c'est un très très beau sport
que j'apprécie beaucoup mais c'est pas
pour autant que voilà cette pratique qui
est quand même assez élitiste mais c'est
vrai qu'on a c'est peut-être aussi moins
en moins facile de pratiquer le biathlon
partout en france ce que tu peux faire
pour le golf les déceptions les
chaussons structurelles sont partout sur
le territoire
il ya des zones qui sont un petit peu
plus privilégiés avec des policiers
juste que c'est de gaulle c'est juste
champion de france et un tiers de
licencier un tiers des licenciés
français sont en effet justin jarrell
entre un sport où on a un vrai champion
qui a rayonné qui qui fait rayonner son
sport et c'est pas pour autant que on a
des pratiquants qui enfin je sais que
les pratiquement augmente ça c'est sûr
mais ce n'est pas de manière
spectaculaire non plus d'accord le golf
sur la neige ça existe trop fois genre
je peux pas citer le nom parce que c'est
il est sponsorisé mais il ya une guerre
des compétitions sera solide peut-être
un jour d'invention par les sports on va
continuer maintenant ce talk par notre
page résultats
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en rugby à ce dimanche 27 mai versailles
a réussi un coup de maître en venant à
bout de l'entente maisons laffitte saint
jean les poissy en huitièmes de finale
du championnat de france honneur le
score 13 à 3 dans une ambiance
électrique en l'écoutant l'action du 2
au nom de l'éthique senior argent à la
grèce
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui je suis alors je crois qu'on
va voir les images du deuxième de la
seconde vague du trophée des entreprises
justement à l'image ils vont partir dans
un instant je le disais il n'y a pas
beaucoup de place sur ligne de départ
est agréable mais qu'est ce qui
s'organise
du coup sa part par vagues et chaque
vague est chronométré et donc du coup
après on sortira le meilleur résultat au
hockey qui est très très bien c'est bon
c'est bien réfléchissez bien
et puis ça évite peut-être d'avoir des
engorgements incertain sur certains
ateliers
dans quelques instants on retrouvera
nicolas d'en rire sur le terrain avec
les compétiteurs on l'a vu une fois on
le reverra une deuxième fois en france
aussi on parler sport on l'espère en
tout cas
alors une victoire on en parlait de
versailles rugby à une victoire acquise
en grande partie grâce à une défense
resserrée dans les derniers mètres qui a
perturbé leurs adversaires on écoute
l'entraîneur jérémy comment jouer de la
défense
kaka fonctionné alors l'entraîneur alain
germain nous a également dévoilé qu'il
n'allait plus entraîner l'équipe la
saison prochaine
on écoute 5 là j'ai appris plus on s'est
mis la pression qu'on voulait chevallier
je me retourne forcément vers vous
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec anna
jamin alors des points mais juste
féliciter les féliciter une fois encore
nos joueurs là qui ont fait un match
effectivement de grande qualité
un compte des fouaces yvette défensive
33 une ville contre trois villes c'est
sa veste et sous une chaleur il chaleur
étouffante donc encore encore une fois
bravo à eux
quant à quant à la suite des soupes aux
alentours du rc versailles avec
intervention de traitement
- s'est passé anti un petit pote de hip
hop et communication
personne personne qui sont courants 2
la suite c'est difficile c'est pas ce
serait difficile à garder une saison de
rugby c'est à la fois long puisqu'il ya
un éliminé longue saison de poule mais
ça passe très vite il faut déjà penser à
la suite
à la suite à la saison suivante on est
dedans on est depuis depuis deux ans
désormais dans un projet à 5 ans dans le
temps avec le bureau qui a été
renouvelée qui a été renouvelée ya deux
ans et lors des discussions qu'on a eues
avec alain le à lens ne s'inscrivait pas
forcément dans la durée avec le rugby
club versailles on a on a en la personne
d'alain un coach un coach de premier
ordre en termes de technique qui nous
fait parfois dire que un autre niveau
honneur on n'a jamais eu de on n'a
jamais eu techniciens comme comme alain
aux manettes et que là c'est le joueur
qui parle les deux les deux dernières
montées que l'umq l on a on a fêté avec
versailles en 2001 et en 2006 elle se
sont fait d'abord sur le facteur humain
et sur le plus que sur la technique
d'ailleurs sur une aventure d'une bande
de copains et qu'ils sont heureux de se
retrouver et qui est qui au bout d'une
saison plus ou moins longues montant
monte en fédérale 3 donc
on avait on avait discuté avec un début
avril après les matches de poule il
était il était dans les plaques de des
phases finales on est on a raté la
montée directe en ne terminant pas
premier de poule puisque c'est sarcelles
qui a pris cette place là et il a fallu
il a fallu imaginer la suite est
vraiment le bureau le bureau du rcv
rubik versailles s'inscrit dans une dans
une démarche
la désormais à 3 ans puisqu'il ya déjà
deux ans qui viennent de s'écouler qui
prévoit la remontée qui espère la
remontée du club en fédérale 3 et eybens
et donc on a dû on a dû se séparer
d'alain alors papa sur le terme virait
kom kom kom sa publicité mais on s'est
inscrit dans une optique de construire
justement sur la durée et et ça
n'empêche pas de lui tirer un très très
grand coup de chapeau parce que c'est un
grand pro et malgré cette cette
déception et l'amertume qui doit qu'il
doit avoir malgré tout ne pas continuer
avec nous ils assurent ils assurent
l'essentiel est justement et notamment
pour préparer le mieux possible l'équipe
du rcv pour son quart de finale contre
chalon le dimanche 10 juin alors la
question sur ce thème le départ du coach
at il égalera knees et les joueurs oui
ou non les jours de versailles en bien
sûr non il n'est pas là je sais pas on
fait un petit duel entre georges et jean
le retour deuxième duel de la journée
georges vous commencez encore non mais
je pense que
le coach m'a déjà c'est un professionnel
et il faut le souligner parce que bon à
prendre
qu'on ait viré puis derrière
avoir cette réaction et garder son
groupe son groupe
comment en éveil pour pour continuer
l'aventuré se trouve ça vraiment
honorable honorable maintenant je pense
pas que les joueurs les joueurs quelque
part bon si on en vient annoncer au
coach qui doit partir c'est qu'il ya
quand même il y avait quand même des
joueurs qui devaient aussi en sous marin
qui devait peut-être en sous marin se
plaindre du coach donc donc là là je
pense pas que les joueurs ils sont 10
bat le coach il va il va être viré et
est aujourd'hui on va jouer notre
meilleur rugby bon locaux je pense que
l'institut le club
tout le monde s'est mobilisé pour le
club parce qu'un objectif il ya une
possibilité de jouer des phases finales
c'est honorable et c'est bien pour tout
le monde et ça si on fait une bonne
campagne couper un georges gomis sur la
coque de l'émission voilà si on arrive à
monter bah tant mieux pour tous genres
c'est à vous d'agir pour moi
la question a été posée est-ce que ça va
galvaniser le groupe
oui je le pense dans la mesure où on
voulait se battre pour lui oui puis pour
avoir eu quelques infos de la part de
deux joueurs ou d'entraîneurs ou de
responsables
et à la remise des maillots qu'ils
avaient quand même énormément d'émotion
pierre on ne peut pas le nier puisqu'ils
étaient investis rqth j'ai eu énormément
d'émotion lorsqu on provoque énormément
d'émotion au sein même d'un groupe avant
un match de cette importance c'est que
les joueurs sont quand même affecter
quelque part du départ de leur
entraîneur ça c'est sûr après que
certains joueurs se sont plaints mais je
suis certain
parce que moi même je suis entraîneur
depuis plus de 30 ans celui qui fait
l'unanimité
il faut vite et qui viennent me serrer
la main parce que ça n'existe pas faire
l'unanimité
donc forcément on ne fait jamais
l'unanimité ne serait ce que dans les
choix qu'on peut l'on peut avoir
lorsqu'on fait la composition de
l'équipe donc forcément il y avait des
joueurs contre mais quand même lors
cette tige ce match là je pense que ça a
galvanisé les joueurs et qui ont permis
aussi de mettre un petit peu plus
d'intensité quand à la défense je sais
ça a été pré mondial sur ce match là
juste pour finir je serai pas très long
je pas le jour mais juste pour finir
quand même une petite parenthèse sa
rentrée dans les détails je pense
qu'avant donné on est dans du rugby
amateur
on n'est pas des professionnels et que
aujourd'hui il faudrait quand même je
passe un message au président aux
différents présidents qui fasse
attention au côté humain parce que des
discours on peut tous en avoir des
excuses on peut tous en trouver mais moi
je trouve encore une fois parce que je
les ai vécus je dois encore une fois
dégueulasse fait mais qu'on annonçait un
entraîneur fier des résultats ou qu'il
en a pas parce que votre chat fou ça
vous est arrivé mais qu'on annonce un
entraîneur fait mais alors que le marché
entre guillemets des clubs est quasiment
fait coucou même quasiment même fait que
connaît le garde pas je trouve
humainement je trouve que il va falloir
quand même que les présidents revoir
leur position rapidement pierre on va
écouter tout de suite nicolas d'andry ce
qui est sûr sur je ne sais pas où il est
né
vous n'êtes qu'à 50
sur le parvis on va la voir dans
quelques instants je le retrouve on va
le retrouver nouveau interrogé par jean
ce que tu dit pierre chevallier rapide
jugeant adjoint a complètement raison et
le bureau du rcv notamment reconnais
tout à fait que que l'etei le timing
n'était pas bon notamment et et pas
respectueux de la suite pour alain
compte tenu de contenu du jeu justement
de l'aide de la suite des événements
néanmoins c'est arrivé et on a essayé on
a essayé autant que faire se peut de
pouvoir de pouvoir expliquer et de
pouvoir justement de pouvoir essayer de
faire passer la pilule effectivement
j'étais dans l'est dans le secret des
vestiaires ça m'a rappelé de bons
souvenirs de grands souvenirs je ne
dirais pas que ça galvanise est
forcément tous les joueurs et l'ensemble
l'ensemble de l'équipe
néanmoins ça a été l'étincelle qui leur
a permis de réaliser qu'ils étaient
capables de faire un gros coup sets
cette saison en phase finale et de est
allé d'aller se goinfraient relais les
meilleures équipes sur le papier
l'opposition entre maisons laffitte
poissy saint germain était coupée je
suis désolé mais je suis désolé je
l'adoré on l'a retrouvé ça y est mais
sûr on vient de retrouver et on voit les
pics enneigés départ je sais pas où
[Musique]
aller jouer par exemple
alors du coup alors comment qui convient
dès que vous avez déjà dans la
compétition quatre équipes est alors du
coup c'était important de venir les
supporter pourquoi
bien sûr mais s'ils ont besoin pour
gagner
[Musique]
gagner bien se placer et participez vous
êtes des habitués ou pas sur cette
compétition
absolument venir les supporter montrer
nos couleurs et se dire notre société
voilà mais il reste encore quelques
vagues de départ et puis même et
peut-être que l'équipe b d obama
remporte pas dans une des catégories
remarque en tout 4 nicolas noguier vous
êtes avec des supports pris fin et non
pas des supporteurs
jarrier super ambiance un sens pour que
les entreprises montre tout simplement
que l'on peut s'amuser au sein
d'entreprises et créer du crédit du lien
douala du lien tout à fait il ya un beau
dynamisme
on va revenir sur sur le rugby à
versailles et est-ce que vous avez un
commentaire vous sur sur sept ce départ
de l'entraîneur je rejoue avec trente
secondes après la fin des missions de
voilages et je rejoins jean c'est vrai
qu'il faut il faut dans le sport amateur
garder un peu d'humanité pour pour
préserver chacun et que tout le monde
puisse avoir sa place pour les saisons à
les saisons suivantes
parce que ben là c'est vrai que c'est
encore un entraîneur qui se retrouvent
sur le carreau et c'est malheureux
justement c'est l'occasion pour
l'ensemble du bureau et l'ensemble du
club de tirer un grand coup de chapeau
aux deux entraîneurs en fait qui nous
quitte
l'entraîneur donc alain jamin et fabrice
larrieu ans pour l'équipe réserve qui a
eu l'année dernière un titre en titre de
champion d'île de france et qui a été
jusqu'en demi finale du championnat de
france
deux réserves honneur donc un grand coup
de chapeau à eux on aurait voulu que ça
se passe un peu mieux dans l' annonce
dans la communication et dans le dans
l'hommage que l'on que l'on leur que l
on leur doit
combien seront forcément mais voilà un
gros coup de chapeau à eux deux on
continuera à suivre en tout cas le
rugby-club de versailles dans les
prochaines manches adjoint quarts de
finale c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouvent le jeudi 14 mois pour un
nouveau talk le prochain rendez-vous
sera consacrée exclusivement football
dans les yvelines
on va terminer par une citation du
joueur le plus titré sur terre battue
rafael nadal on gagne plus avec le
choeur avec la volonté qu avec autre
chose je vous laisse méditer sur cette
phrase à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a besoin